download the new one path network app
for the latest islamic videos
watch all your favorite video content
anywhere
anytime available on ios and android
today
[Music]
imagine having guests and they have to
witness that makes me sick
guys but in our new studio it's totally
different
and this is our entrance to our new
studio amazing
guys this is salaam studio toilets
i feel embarrassed i swear to god i feel
embarrassed
when guests come to do videos for for
them to come here
and use the toilet check this out this
is our toilet guys
yeah it's embarrassing not an animal
deserves to live here let alone human
beings how we're going to ask our guests
to come and do we'll do here
no hot water freezing cold disgusting
but with our new studio check the
toilets out
guys isn't hot water amazing of course
it is and this is
our new toilet in our new studio finally
this is our current studio we're
supposed to give dao on this high road
where is everyone
but check out our new studios high road
and this bronze sisters is our new high
road where people
actually exist look at this this is
tottenham court high road bombing
sisters
and here you've got people coming each
other and we're going to set our dowel
stool
right at this spot inshallah this very
location is going to be our dao strobe
sisters and if anybody accepts islam all
we have to do is take them to our studio
and teach them how to do
and to pray this is salaam studios check
out our neighbors
come here
this is what's next door come come come
come come
now check out our new neighbors in our
new studio our old neighbors were
terrible these neighbors are amazing
follow me guys check this out
we have next door neighbors yeah i seen
youth they do amazing work with the
youth
and we have them next door to us and we
have access
to all of this so if we do youth events
or anything like that
bronze sisters we have access to all of
this
[Laughter]
let's see that anytime and that is
successful sisters
and that will be all thanks to you guys
if you can donate in that league broken
sisters
we will have access to all of this
inshallah may allah bless you guys